hoy martes volvemos al estudio directo
américa de france 24 con rosa pérez más
de rosa bienvenida abrimos de revista de
prensa con un fragmento de la entrevista
que se dio ayer el portavoz del kremlin
a la red de televisión pública
estadounidense hablamos de la lluvias
buenos días raúl exactamente no una vez
más pues evidentemente la postura del
kremlin ha sido noticia en los medios de
comunicación alrededor del mundo y vamos
a comentar ciertos puntos de esta
entrevista empezando por la pregunta que
le hace el periodista ryan chilcot al
portavoz del kremlin dmitri peskov y el
periodista le comenta bueno la posición
de rusia respecto al potencial uso de
las armas nucleares en el contexto de la
invasión de ucrania es un poco confusa
no rusia ha reiterado que se reserva el
derecho de usar este tipo de armamento
si la existencia del estado ruso se ve
amenazado pero el periodista le pregunta
qué significaría este tipo de amenaza es
decir en que se materializaría y peskov
responde de una forma un tanto ambigua
que hay para por un lado la intervención
la operación especial militar en ucrania
de la amenaza la existencia del estado
ruso también recuerda que cuando putin
anunció esta operación especial advirtió
que en ningún país se debería intervenir
e insiste peskov también en que en
cualquier caso si rusia se ve amenazada
pues usarían este armamento nuclear no
entonces el periodista le dice entonces
si interviene otro país ustedes usarían
las armas nucleares dice no no creo el
periodista continúa insistiendo y si te
parece escuchemos cómo acaba esta
conversación
work
mire señor peskov si se atiene a su
definición del diccionario de amenaza
existencial que estábamos discutiendo
claramente nada de lo que está
ocurriendo de lo que realmente
francamente imaginable que pueda ocurrir
podría alcanzar ese nivel de amenaza la
existencia del estado ruso entonces por
qué no aclarar esto ahora mismo porque
usted el nombre de rusia no puede
descartar el uso de armas nucleares en
este conflicto aquí mismo
nadie está pensando en usar ni siquiera
en la idea de usar un arma nuclear
bueno los vamos a ver qué pasa porque
hice una cosa y hacen otra
exactamente no al final acaba siendo
bastante claro peskov a ver pues
esperamos superó los que realmente se
mantengan evidentemente pues fieles a
sus palabras otro de los titulares que
deja esta entrevista es la de nupel
mente no gas no hay pago no hay gas en
referencia a esta condición que puso
putin donde que la unión europea pagará
el gas en la moderna en la moneda rusa
en rublos vamos a ver también pero vamos
querido seleccionar pues nada tres
titulares que resumen esta entrevista
por un lado el wall street journal dice
el portavoz del kremlin rebaja la
amenaza de usar armas nucleares de times
sin embargo reitera un poco esta
formulación que hemos visto ya
anteriormente respecto este tema rus a
usar a rusia usará armas nucleares sólo
si su existencia está en peligro y al
final la agencia rusa estás es la que
acaba destacando no pues esta conclusión
final de pskov nadie en rusia está
pensando en usar armas nucleares bueno
así lo recoge la prensa entonces y rosa
ayer hablaste con mi querida ángela
gómez que hicieron cinco periodistas
rusos al presidente de una entrevista no
que hicieron sí con periodistas rusos el
presidente ucraniano por el mercedes key
y que fue censurada esto en rusia the
gardian hace referencia a este encuentro
y se pregunta servirá de algo
exactamente esto lo intenta responder el
corresponsal de the gardian en moscú
hablamos de andrew ross recuerda que en
esta entrevista participaron a cinco
periodistas rusos dos de ellos de medios
rusos
vivo al menos hasta ayer 1 del nóvaya
gazeta y otro del comercio recordemos
que nóvaya gazeta anunció ayer el cese
temporal de las operaciones mientras
dure esta operación especial y por otro
lado también participaban en periodistas
de los medios medusa que también es ruso
pero está basado en letonia de la
televisión 2 que se traduce como reina
lluvia y una periodista independiente
llamado mikael llegar y explica este
corresponsal bien la voluntad desde
lentes que al dar esta entrevista con la
prensa rusa era hacer llegar una vez más
el discurso ucraniano a la población de
rusia y hacerlo en ruso pues
precisamente esto para que no haya
traducciones no hay interferencias para
mandar un mensaje claro en la que
también es la lengua materna del
presidente ucraniano sin embargo el
corresponsal de the gardian dice los
rusos que están digamos dispuestos a ir
a consultar estas a páginas web de
medusa o de la televisión rain ya son
ciudadanos que están dispuestos
predispuestos a oír un mensaje
alternativo al mensaje oficial del
kremlin por lo que digamos la el
presidente de lenski va a quedar un poco
frustrada ya que no va a acabar pues
derrocando lo que es el discurso oficial
y como comentaba también recordar que en
la prensa rusa esta entrevista fue
bloqueada y solo se pidió poder
consultar a través de telegram cómo ha
ido circulando a través de los canales
de youtube de como decíamos medusa
activa y rain y del periodista
independiente de mikel llegar a través
de vpn desde rusia rosa rápidamente nos
quedamos con medusa que destaca los
pilares de la prensa rusa se han
derrumbado pero los periodistas que
trabajan en esas publicaciones continúan
trabajando a qué se refiere así a saúl
hemos querido simplemente pues destacar
que medusa hace un recopilatorio de los
periodistas que han ido dejando sus
puestos de trabajo básicamente porque
sus medios han sido censurados o han
cesado operaciones pero que continúan
informando y dan pues y noticias digamos
alternativas a lo que es el discurso del
kremlin a través de canales de tele
gramo de youtube y les animamos a que
entren a consultar este artículo para
ver un poco estos canales alternativos
de información en rosa y con ese ánimo
rosa pasamos entonces a saludar a
nuestro primero invitado del día gracias
por toda la revista de prensa mañana con
más